two bits but still okay yeah yeah
farrakhan's quite happy to have lots of
qubits as long as there are no
categories yeah so indeed what I want to
talk about today is this connection with
quantum mechanics and and and to go in
in in enough detail to see exactly how
the kind of tables which we've been
discussing can be arise directly from
the predictions of quantum mechanics and
this leads on to an interesting
theoretical question which is how
complicated is this class of such tables
which are generated by quantum mechanics
and there's an interesting and
apparently quite deep open question
there which I think can be interesting
to logicians and also seems to be
related to well-known open problems in
in operator algebra and otherwise so I
thought I'd start just by a brief review
of Hilbert spaces mainly to say that
what we need to know here is is is not
not not very much Hilbert spaces play
obviously at a basic setting for the
formalization of quantum mechanics as we
indicated in the timeline that we
discussed in the first lecture that the
current foundations for ordinary quantum
mechanics which provides the basis for
pretty much all discussion in quantum
information and computation and the
foundations laid down by John von
Neumann in his book mathematical
foundations of quantum mechanics
published in English in 1932 German
version a few years earlier and this is
based on Hilbert spaces Hilbert spaces
are so named by von Neumann as a kind of
homage to David Hilbert there is a story
probably apocryphal that Hilbert was
listening to one of Von Neumanns
lectures and he at some point he he sort
of leaned over to his neighbor and said
what are these Hilbert spaces
anyway a hilbert space is so what we did
what we need to say is that the hilbert
spaces are complex in a product space
and then in general it can be infinite
dimensional there's a norm defined from
the inner product and the space has to
be complete in this norm physicists are
often very quite cavalier about the
analytical aspects so we know that we've
so it's a vector space with an inner
product and the thing that we can mainly
think of we'll see why in a moment is
just think of C to the N complex vector
space n-dimensional complex vector space
everything is complex vectors and
matrices the salient notion of basis for
Hilbert spaces is a vector space basis
which is moreover orthonormal so it
consists of pairwise orthogonal unit
vectors orthogonal T of a pair of
vectors they're sort of at right angles
to each other perpendicular to each
other just at the inner product goes to
0 and Hilbert spaces are incredibly
rigid up to isomorphism there is only
one Hilbert space in each dimension so
dimension is cardinality of orthonormal
basis and that's an invariant of the
space and up to isomorphism there is
only one Hilbert space in each dimension
which means that in principle the
possibility is for ordinary quantum
mechanics or the finite dimensional
hilbert space is C to the N and the
countably the separable hilbert space
whose representation are not the only
one but whose standard representation is
just countable sequences of complex
numbers bounded in the l2 norm and
that's it
the buffet there's a famous
correspondence between this sequence
space and a much fancier looking thing
the so-called big L 2 space which is the
one where the wave functions live which
we usually taught in them
introductory quantum mechanics course
the two things are the same and this is
really the correspondence between the
well this thing which of course is a
standard piece of mathematics is a
correspondence between the Schrodinger
wave function picture and the Heisenberg
matrix mechanics picture which were the
two original founding formulations of
quantum mechanics which were then rigged
Erised by Hilbert and they come they're
actually describing the same separable
Hilbert space so for ordinary quantum
mechanics in principle that's all there
is I say in principle because
pragmatically a different representation
with a different choice of basis can
have a lot of value in actually modeling
problems and indeed in the introductory
course as I saying people don't use this
sequence space they use the space of the
Big L 2 space of functions on a
configuration space and in by the way so
one might say well you know the the
modern way of doing things would be with
C star algebras and it's it's CSR LT was
very elegant algebraic structure very
much studied but not really more general
by the famous GILF on my mark theorem
every C star algebra is isomorphic to a
sub algebra of the bounded operators on
a Hilbert space so we're back to Hilbert
spaces and actually most of quantum
information restricts consideration to
the finite dimensional cases so really
just with complex inner product spaces
of finite dimensions the the seat of the
Earth's eye an objection perhaps
the well I'm referring to a result which
says which says this not due to gelfand
on my mark I mean there is of course the
Gulf and I mark duality theorem from the
commutative case but there is a theorem
that says that every C star algebra is
isomorphic to a sub algebra B of H I
thought it was u2 Gelfand environment
okay right right so it so there it's so
it's not that girl for my thing actually
I think there isn't that called a girl
font representation theorem the
commutative case so the GILF on my mark
is that is the case for general c star
algebra okay so as i say most of contact
is if you think of a quantum circuit
they're going to be finitely many qubits
you think of a protocol for quantum
cryptography all those situations we're
dealing with finitely many degrees of
freedom and we're just in finite
dimensions now mostly then your algebra
is taught as a very introductory course
and you might think well if quantum
information is just about finite
dimensional linear algebra isn't that
trivial and the answer of course is no
it's kind of interesting in a way
there's an analogy with the the sort of
measure Theory probability theory thing
I mean I so we could say that you know
the measure that I mean probability
theory is a vastly richer and more
interesting subject than measure theory
Lively a subject that measure theory I
think this is going to annoy prakasha or
not but
even though in a sense it's a special
case because it has so much to be about
and so many concepts that come in from
all the things that you model with with
probability theory and in a sense
something like that is is going on when
we come to quantum information even
though the medium for most of it is fine
it is just matrices operators on finite
dimensional complex linear algebra
there's a whole wealth of notions that
come in so that's part of the answer as
and indeed we'll see what I think is a
challenging open problem a bit later in
this lecture which uses no more than
finite dimension well which raises the
issue of dimensionality in an
interesting way another reason there's
more to it than just what one encounters
in a introductory course in linear
algebra is that something plays a very
important role in quantum information
which doesn't usually show up in an
introductory linear algebra course and
this is the tensor product and as one
might say the multilinear aspect as well
as just the linear algebra aspect so the
point this is very important this is the
way we put systems together in in
quantum mechanics and this is already in
Norman's book although he doesn't have a
very explicit discussion of the tensor
product it would appear in a more modern
account compound systems if you have a
system represented by a Hilbert space H
and another system represented by a
Hilbert space K in general the way you
put them together is not by taking a
direct product kind of construction but
but a tensor program and this is exactly
where Alice and Bob live this is why you
get all these interesting multi-party
protocols entanglement and so on this
all lives in typically in tensor product
spaces and the point is that the
possibilities in the tensor product are
not just limited to a possibility from
one come one factor together with a
possibility from the other you get you
get superpositions and you get the
phenomena we associate with entanglement
so there's lots one can say about tensor
product from from the more abstract
point of view if we bring in categories
then we would have a beautiful symmetric
monoidal structure and in finite
dimensions we have a sort of home tense
and uality and all kinds of beautiful
things come out from that but for our
purposes here let's just be very
concrete and say that if H has an
orthonormal basis say the Veck
- SIA and K has an orthonormal basis Phi
J then we can build an orthonormal basis
for the tensor product as pairs of basis
vectors from the two components and you
see immediately from this in finite
dimensions that if the dimension of H is
M and the dimension of K is n then the
dimension of H tensor K is going to be M
times n and also then it becomes very
plausible that this looks like a matrix
of entries from the to the two Hilbert
spaces and so you can almost see from
this that this kind of the fact that you
can view elements of the tensor product
as actually being linear maps from one
factor to the other and a lot of the
ideas about information flow in in
quantum protocols can be articulated
from that point of view if we represent
qubit space with a standard basis so
this is the Dirac ket notation but it's
just too basic well this is two
dimensional complex Hilbert space they
are the two basis vectors and the idea
is a general state can be some super
linear combination of these things as it
were some superstition superposition
between being in the state 0 and being
in the state 1 as is often said then
just by iterating this you see that the
the basis for an N qubit state will be
indexed by all the binary strings of
length n and this is the exponential
growth of the space as we if we go to n
as as the end grows in me and in the
cubed root
okay so so that by way of background so
we want to talk about how the the the
sort of situations we've been describing
where we have these empirical models
things that describe data that we could
observe which of those could arise from
quantum mechanics that's that yes
comparing before these next row spaces
but here you have a topology well as I
was saying and mostly we're go we're not
going to be to talk about that because
we're mostly just going to be in finite
dimensions but of course it is a serious
question when when you go to the
infinite dimensional cases yes this was
the this was the the point here what I'm
saying yeah what I'm saying is that in
in quantum information we're mostly just
looking at finite dimensions and you
might think then that all the
interesting stuff in quantum mechanics
came from the infinite dimensional
aspects and the analytical aspects that
arise from solving the Schrodinger
equation and so on but actually quantum
information is here to tell us that
there's a wealth of subtlety even in
these finite dimensional situation I'm
sure I hear a lot more about that in
their Simona's talk you know this
afternoon and part of the reason for
that is this multilinear aspect that we
just briefly mentioned here with the
tensor product okay so the it's actually
around the wonderful thing that quantum
mechanics although in some ways it's
very puzzling is one of the physical
theories that has been axiom Atty x'd
with a high degree of mathematical
precision in some ways it's much it's
much harder to actually bataille some of
the theories of classical physics
without were there in in in us in a cop
to a comparable level and this was
achieved by by von neumann around 1930 I
mean there's another very influential
presentation by Dirac which was less
rigorous
and involved those Dirac Delta functions
that Prakash mentioned in his lectures
but the standard thing that people use
is for ordering quantum mechanics and
use on a day to day basis in in in in
the working quantum information is this
axiomatic presentation I should mention
by way of contrast that the situation is
very different when you go to quantum
field theory which is the setting for
current day particle physics so it's
it's a much richer subject but also the
issue of mathematically rigorous even
though quantum field theory more or less
started in the 1930s and was sort of
fully formed in some sense by that I
guess by the late 40s but the issue of
rate of making it rigorous and at the
same time adequate to the sort of
phenomena that standard model and so on
the people are working with in in
current day experiments remains quite a
well it what it remains quite a divided
a challenging question although not
necessarily one that's interesting to
physicists who are quite happy with
their way of doing quantum field theory
but at any rate we don't have to worry
about that because we're we're just
dealing with standard with basic as it
were ordinary quantum mechanics which is
used as a working tool not only in
quantum information but in vast ways of
condensed matter physics and lots of
other stuff that's so what are the
ingredients of this axiomatization
states of the system are given by unit
vectors in complex Hilbert space as
andreas was mentioning in his talk the
other day there's some redundancy in
this because it's up to up to a global
phase a complex scalar factor of of unit
modulus
that doesn't give significant
information to the state so a better way
of saying what the state is is is to
identify it with the corresponding one
dimensional subspace the Ray which is
generated by the vector but in practice
for calculational purposes people
usually use vectors dynamics are given
by the Schrodinger equation whose
solutions are given by unitary maps on
the hilbert space in whereas in in
modeling physical systems this place has
paramount importance and it's all about
finding the right Hamiltonian to
describe the physical system in question
in quantum information this kind of
dwindles and and you actually very
rarely see the Schrodinger equation you
never see that h-bar constant and
actually what one works with is the
unitary Maps and if you think of a
circuit a gate in a quantum computation
it just is a unitary map and those are
the building blocks for describing
larger quantum processes so as one takes
a different point of view and ask
different kinds of questions different
aspects of the formalism become more
important than come to the fore and
others somewhat lesser observables the
the kind of measurements we can perform
are given by self adjoint operators on
the on the hilbert space so self adjoint
well we have so we have a the adjoint of
a matrix of a complex matrix is just the
conjugate transpose of the matrix to
take the transpose and conjugate all the
entries take the complex conjugates of
all the entries now here's a beautiful
thing that when we come to giving this
an operational interpretation so self
adjoint operators the spectral theorem
of linear algebra tells us that a self
adjoint operator can be written in a in
a diagonal basis that we get an
orthonormal basis and we can write it in
this form and these are the
I give vectors of the basis and these
are the eigenvalues
the point is operationally they're that
you think of the I mean how does a
self-adjoint operator represent a
measurement well you think of these
different elements of the the spectral
resolution as giving you the different
possible outcomes so the eigenvalues
would be it would label the the kind of
values you observe for the different
outcomes and this is yes yes yes that's
a bit sloppy writing it like that
figures I'm using the well yes so we
could have the projection the projectors
yeah you're right but I am gonna use
vectors to represent the projection
operators when I do the calculations
which is Rio I wrote it in this slightly
sloppy fashion and in particular I'm
going to use this as my formulation of
the born rule so because otherwise we
get into trace and so on sorry
there we are yes I'm really getting into
into it so it's quite addictive you
start taking all these shortcuts so this
is this is a really important point
because this all looks like some maths
and so on and I mean no bubble we in the
end we want to get a number which would
be a probability which we can relate to
what we see in the lab when we actually
set up an experiment and perform
measurements so this is the thing we
called the born rule which gives us that
basic predictive information so the
press so if we're in a state given by
some vector psi then the probability of
getting the outcome labeled by this
lambda I is going to be given by the
square modulus of this inner product so
this is what the born rule says and that
will be a non-negative real number and
actually these will even normalize
nicely
and we'll get a probability distribution
on the outcomes so some so this is a
sort of very brief take on this exhibit
ization someone should make some caveats
of course it's important to know in any
kind of realistic setting if we're
considering information to consider the
fact that we that we have noisy
environments unsharp measurements
unsharp preparations so there's an
evident and therefore one studies mixed
rather than pure states density
operators rather than vectors unsharp
measurements represented by a so called
POV m as positive operator valued
measurements rather than the projective
measurements often called von neumann
measurements in fact of the kind we were
describing here and so on so forth and
this is all true but in some sense it
doesn't matter and because one can
always resort to a larger dimensional
hilbert space and recover mixed from
pure states and unsharp from sharp
measurements so you think of the
representing the activity of the
environment by adding extra stuff
usually called the ancilla which
represents the extra degrees of freedom
you can't directly observe and then sort
of tracing out as it were marginalizing
from that and this mixes in all the
noise you're getting from the
environment from what would have
otherwise been a sharp description and
formally this is underwritten by results
such as the stein spring dilation
theorem and there's a nice phrase do i
think to john small in where one appeals
to the church of the larger hilbert
space so therefore one isn't really at
the fundamental level or at least in
theory and you know as they say the
difference between theory and practice
is not very great in theory but not in
practice so so in so in principle this
is a perfectly good description of what
going on and even if we many purposes
would use would sort of use these more
general representations we could reduce
them to the case of pure states and
sharp measurements in this fashion and
this will anyway we'll take this as our
justification for sticking to the
simplest level of presentation okay so
the important thing is we're ready
hinted with mention of the the born rule
that these mathematical structures can
be associated with operational
procedures which can be performed in the
lab or observed in nature or nowadays
can be built into the devices that
people are trying to build to turn these
ideas into quantum technology devices
for doing quantum cryptography quantum
computation and so forth so there are
preparation procedures to produce
quantum states I mean they're actually
well established optical procedures for
producing entangled pairs of of states
there are measurement devices with
things like photon detectors now
achieving very impressive levels of
efficiency which is one of the reasons
why some of those experiments that I
mentioned in the opening lecture have
been so impressively successful recently
interferometers and various other things
and there are and and of course then we
get these empirical probabilities of
getting outcomes when measuring a state
produced by some preparation process P
with measurement device D and then you
can do exactly the kind of abstraction
we have been doing where you're saying
rather than you know you know rather
than presupposing a particular elaborate
physical theory with its own
mathematical structure such as quantum
mechanics let's just look at the general
setting where you have some preparation
procedures some clauser preparation
procedure some class of measurements and
rules that tell you what probabilities
you have of getting out comes from
prepper
with measurements in a given settings
this leasing model called generalized
probabilistic theories as a means of
studying the space of possible physical
theories via their operational content
and this has been quite a fruitful
perspective on studying quantum
information in this in this broader
setting and I would say all of this has
been directly inspired by Bell's Theorem
and the whole the whole nature of it is
really leaving one in this direction
that one rather than presupposing a
particular theory one is really looking
at the space of possible theories and
what is possible within that matters of
course a point of view that should be
very congenial to a logician for a
logicians point of view for example so
this and this is Laird actually also two
interesting things in applications such
as so-called device independent quantum
key distribution where you're relying
only on observation the violation of
Bell inequalities without presupposing
that the Box you've got is operating
according to the rules of quantum
mechanics in order to give the
cryptographic guarantees and the device
independent perspective is is is also
now going into studies of the quantum
complexity for example the sort of
generalized quantum complexity okay so
but now let's come back to the quantum
representation so this here we're
emphasizing this operational point of
view but now we when we look at the
quantum representation we have these
complex numbers we have these Hilbert
spaces and somehow from them we get
things that we can relate to these these
operational considerations in particular
we have the basic model of the qubit so
a qubit is is is living where you just
have two degrees of freedoms it's the
basic unit for information processing
just as in the classical case the bit is
so it's two-dimensional complex vector
space so we would represent it by for
real numbers but we're looking at unit
vectors
so we get a constraint and nor
normalization constraint so we can
represent things with three real numbers
and then again as andreas was describing
in his talk last week there's this
representation in terms of I mean this
is linked to this representation by the
group of real love real rotations there
so three then rate we get this
representation on the sphere where a
state a pure state corresponds to a
point on the surface of the sphere a
nice point is that with the convex
closure of this gives us all the fills
in the whole solids sphere gives us the
mixed States as well but anyway the pure
States live on the surface and the sorry
the the ball I should say but the pure
States live on the surface so this is
the one cubit case and we can visualize
it like this and then if we're going to
think of measurement we choose a
direction to say of spin or whether
we're detecting a photon polarization
whatever so we choose we choose a
direction in space and that determines a
pair of antipodal points on the sphere
which give us the direction say spin up
and spin down and we have the state and
when we measure we're projecting the
state down onto this axis chosen to be
for the for the measurement and the
angles actually determine the
probabilities with which we get the art
one of the two possible answers spin up
or spin down for the measurement given
on that state so so the the salient
properties of a qubit from our point of
view so states of the qubit as we're
saying you're represented as points on
the surface of the sphere so there's a
continue of such things obviously we're
in the complex vector space each pair of
antipodal points define a possible
measurement when we subject a qubit to a
measurement
given by this pair of antipodal points
the state of a qubit determines a
probability distribution on the two
possible outcomes and these
probabilities are determined by the
angles between the state and the points
which specify the measurement now of
course you could take the points turn
them into projectors and have this kind
of operant more maybe more
mathematically nice operator formulation
of the measurement but I know I'm just
doing things in this very concrete
fashion so in algebraic terms these are
all unit vectors in this complex vector
space and the probability of observing
say spin up one of the two possible
outcomes in states I is just given as we
were saying by this born rule which is
just the square modulus of the inner
product of the two vectors and this
gives the basic predictive content of
quantum mechanics when it when it comes
right down to it so qubits two
generalized bits in that for each
question we can ask there are just two
possible answers and we can view the
states of the qubit of superpositions of
the classical state 0 and 1 so that
rather than having a single determinate
answer you get probabilities for each of
the two possible answers but there are
also a lot of different questions that
we can ask and this is a dis analogy
with the classical bit as it were with a
classical bit there's only one basis and
we're going to get the answer 0 & 1 but
we have this many different directions
for many different questions that we can
ask in the case of the qubit and we get
this issue of compatibility we cannot
simultaneously observe up or down in two
different directions and the other point
is that a measurement has an effect on
the state which will no longer be the
original state but actually will be
collapsed into the state one up or down
that we were measuring in so this is
what's indicated here as a result of
doing the measurement this state is
going to end up either
pointing their or pointing or being
there or being there so it's this is
often put by saying that quantum
measurement has a kind of retro
addictive effect it doesn't actually
tell you where the state was before but
you know after immediately afterwards
where it is by the answer that you get
from the measurement so this also means
that if you you know in them with
appropriate it also means that if you do
the same measurement twice in succession
you'll get the same answer the second
time as you got the first time in so it
means that we can use measurement and
also to do preparation because if we
want to put a state to be for example
here if you measure it and let's say you
wanted it to be here if you measure it
and if you got if you well if you get
the answer down you've got it where you
want it to be if you get the answer up
you just do the measurement again until
eventually you get this this answer and
then you know where it is
okay now things get really interesting
when we have more than one qubit because
then the phenomenon of entanglement
arises we already discussed this a bit
and this is where things live in the
tensor product where because of the fact
that we get these linear combinations
that we can get correlations between the
components so if some of these
coefficients go to zero we can get
things that look like this and this this
while still looking mathematical
formulation is exactly what underlies
these ideas about spooky action at a
distance and a nonlocality
which in some sense Bell's Theorem is
showing is an unavoidable aspect of the
what quantum mechanics is telling us
because it can't be accounted for by any
local hidden variable theory
okay so here's that table again and the
important point is that this table is
physically realizable it's generated by
this Bell State and exactly this state
by the way is the kind of thing that is
typically generated as an entangled pair
with with current quite reliable optics
technology and we can then so that's one
ingredient we have this state and then
we can get these actual probabilities by
having suitable measurements in the XY
plane at a suitable angle to each other
so what we want to do is actually I want
to actually just go through the just to
be completely concrete and specific to
go through an example of computing an
entry in the table just to just to see
how it comes out from this this
representation so we're going to see is
the state sitting obviously is not I
mean this is the state sitting somewhere
on the surface of the Blas fear we're
going to be interested in choosing for
the settings that Alice and Bob can take
vectors lying in the equatorial plane of
the sphere so if I have so I can take
the X for example as so the spin up is
going in this direction and the point
anti totally opposite on the equatorial
plane will be spin down so a general
description of a vector lying on the
equatorial plane is given like this
where we have a phase factor giving us
the so it's a mixture of these so if the
spin up is is in the Z direction it's
going to be a mixture of the the point
up at the North Pole and the point up at
the the point down at the South Pole
with a suitable phase factor to give us
an angle and these will be expressions
so the and there'll be a pair of
antipodal points so if one of them
and spit-up has its angle given here
then we need to add PI to the angle to
get the antipodal point so very
concretely these are the two vectors
that specify a measurement in the
equatorial plane of the Blas fear so if
if it's X itself then that we just take
the angle to be 0 and this is the
standard X vector so a sort of basis
here is given by these Co ordinate
vectors which relate to the power the
operators the power lease pin operations
okay
and then we just get these two vectors
every one reasonably happy with this any
questions
so they're just vectors anyway and we
can so let's say we we want I want to
justify this entry in the table how do I
do it well what we're doing here is
taking era we're taking one of our
measurement settings to be the vector X
itself and the other to be the vector
still on the equatorial plane but at an
angle PI over 3 to X so just in this
format that we showed here and Alice and
Bob are going to use each the same
measurement on their own qubit so they
have we have a two qubit system on
Alice's qubit she measures either in
Direction X or in the direction and
angle PI over 3 to X Bob does the same
measurements but on his Cupid so what
does an event like this correspond to
Alice chooses measurement a which is
just measuring in the direction X Bob
chooses measurement B prime which is
measuring in the angle PI over 3 2 X so
those are the vectors that represent and
and then we're interested in the outcome
0 1 so that's been up for Alice and
spin-down for Bob and therefore these
are the vectors that correspond to those
outcomes so that's Alice on her qubit
Bob on his qubit we need to take the
tensor product in order to get the joint
outcome of these things okay and then
what you do with the two combined
vectors with the tensor product is just
multiply out bearing in mind that the
tensor product is a Mott is a bilinear
thing so it should distribute over all
the all the sums on all the linear /
linear structure on both sides so we
multiply out cross multiply out we get
four terms over here that look like this
okay it's just so this is the vector in
four in four dimensions which is the
joint measurement by
listen Bob and it's this measurement
which we're going to perform on the
entangled state which we have here this
Bell state and according to the born
rule we're just going to take the square
modulus of this inner product
okay so now we're just down to just
doing some ordinary algebra on complex
vectors so we can do that now the point
is that all these vectors are pairwise
orthogonal as a point about having an
orthonormal basis so when each mold when
each is brought against a different
vector it goes to zero so actually the
two vectors here will just select out
the two corresponding components here
and everything else will go to zero and
what we're left with is this expression
here just we end up just with their
corresponding coefficients we're doing
nothing more than doing inner products
of vectors and well we go through and
remember a little complex algebra and we
end up with lo and behold the
probability one eight one over eight
there's something amazing about I find
out about this in the sense that we go
through this detour in all this geometry
complex numbers and so on and we end up
with something very operational a
probability which we can relate to these
operational procedures that is in some
sense than one of the mysteries of
quantum mechanics and really all the
other entries can be computed similarly
this is the whole story of how we get
these tables so as I say mysteries of
the quantum representation operationally
we see readings on measurement
instruments and observed probabilities
and outcomes we never see a complex
number but quantum mechanics essentially
uses this representation to compute the
positive real numbers corresponding to
what we actually observe I mean in terms
of the numbers we see on readings I mean
obviously we choose units
anyway and they're gonna be you know
just kind of readings on dials so we
never see a complex number we just see
labels for the different outcomes and we
see probabilities we get frequencies and
yet we have to go through this highly
non-obvious representation in in in
complex Hilbert space to compute this
and then it corresponds remarkably well
to empirical observation so of course
there's a kind of comparator question
what explanation can we give for this
and indeed over the last well really a
long time but but with perhaps with
renewed energy over the last 15 years or
so there been many attempts to find
compelling axioms for from which the
quantum well at what's particularly
being true over the last 15 years or so
is emphasizing this operational point of
view and attempts to find compelling
axioms from which starting as it were
from this operational reality that we
have to to get axioms from which the
representation in complex Hilbert space
can be derived to answer the question
why why a Hilbert space is the right
thing and one of the particularly
influential papers that started this
whole direction off was one by Lucy and
Hardy quantum mechanics from five
reasonable axioms around 2001 the same
hard years of how these paradox
incidentally and then there have been
attempts by quite a lot of other people
in a similar vein perhaps most notably
by the pavia group who've got a very
nice presentation which has been quite
quite influential mar'ied Ariano Julie
Julie okie rubella and Palo para naughty
but I think it's fair to say that none
of these there's always some axiom of a
more mathematical nature or you know
that so I don't think the question is
fully fully been answered it remains
something of a something of a mystery
but if anyone has any okay so
but that's where we are so hopefully now
it's clear how in an unambiguous and
precise way quantum mechanics can
generate tables of the kind we've been
considering and the particular table
here as we say is completely generated
in the way we've described it's possible
to by adjusting the angles a bit to get
a similar but slightly different table
which gives a higher winning probability
of success for that XOR game we were
describing in the first lecture actually
there's there's a provable Mac optimal
winning probability that can be achieved
by quantum mechanics actually so the
classical limit was not 0.75 the quantum
account this is as we remember had a
violation of a quarter of the of the
Bell inequality so it has a success
probability of naught point eight one
you can actually get up to naught point
eight three which is the the provable
optimum by quantum mechanics and then on
the other hand you have the PR box which
which has which is a winning strategy
success probability one and cannot be
achieved in quantum mechanics again
another mystery is why does quantum
mechanics take us so far but no further
okay so yeah there's the PR box and and
it satisfies no signaling as we've
discussed so it's consistent with
relativity but not quantum realizable so
a good picture which we'll return to in
more more detail in the next lecture
well I just did because that well okay I
mean there is this bound on the the the
maximum violation you can get a
rebellion equality by quantum realizable
model which equivalently put is the
maximum success probability we can get
for the XOR game which is noir point
eight three and here it's one so that's
actually the the
sort of direct proof but the whole but
the whole question of whether given a
table I mean we can check whether it's
no signaling quite easily it's just a
bunch of linear equations but is it
quantum realizable that is a subtle
question and that's what we're now going
to discuss the question is also to do is
in general for any yes we're interested
doing this for any model and that's what
I'm gonna discuss now so here's a
picture the bell inequalities bound what
could be achievable by non contextual
models models with a classical source
they form a polytope and if we fix the
the the measurement scenario they
remember the number of measurements and
outcomes and so forth then we get a
shape for this polytope we get a
well-defined set of models that live in
the non contextual zone so I've drawn it
nice and I mean it's a polytope there's
a larger pollito which properly includes
this non contextual one of all the no
signaling models which again they're
defined by some equations marginals have
to coincide and again they're obviously
have to be probabilities so it's another
polytope which includes the non
contextual one and sitting between these
two polytopes is the quantum set which
properly includes the non contextual
models and is properly included as we've
just said in the in the no signaling
polytope and this set is convex and
closed but it's not a polytope there
isn't a complete set of inequalities
that characterizes
linear inequalities that characterizes
it and a key question is to find
compelling reasons to explain why nature
picks out the quantum set somewhat a lie
to the question we were just considering
well here I guess question of why why
the quantum specifically so let me just
briefly put on a general footing this
idea of realizing a an empirical model
in the way we've been describing it is
essentially just a general formulation
of what we've seen in in particular
cases actually here I'm only doing it
for the Bell kind of scenario but one
can do it more generally for any any
empirical model over any measurement
scenario of the kind that we we
discussed last time see we have n agents
each agent can choose any of the
measurements from the set mi and the
possible outcomes to come from the set H
I so to represent this we pick a Hilbert
space for each of the agents so they can
then you live in the tensor product
generally generalizing the sort of Alice
Bob situation and for each possible
measurement and outcome for that
measurement we have a unit vector in our
simple representation of measurements in
such a way that these vectors form an
orthonormal basis actually this is not
as general as it as it could be but
it'll do for our purposes
so we're basically we're assigning
quantum measurements as represented by
the sort of orthonormal basis we get out
of the spectral resolution for a
measurement operator and then so there's
a vector associated with each outcome of
the measurement and the state is some
other vector a unit vector sitting in
the tensor product and then for each
choice of measurement of each agent
choosing a measurement from their set
and qhorin a corresponding outcome for
each of those measures
then what the born rule is telling us is
that the probability given that we're in
this state and we're performing these
quantum measurements the probability of
getting that joint outcome when those
measurement settings are selected is
given as we've already seen now several
times by the born rule which is this
square modulus of an inner product so
this is just what we would concrete a
computing concretely earlier writ large
in a more general setting and we take QM
to be the class of empirical models
which are realized by quantum systems in
this fashion so this is now a
mathematically well-defined class as I
say here I'm only looking at Bell
scenarios we could do it more generally
for any empirical model over any
measurement scenario but we get into
slightly more level so we take for a
given Bell scenario like this we can
stratify this set by saying taking QM of
D to be the subclass of models
realizable in the Hilbert space of
finite dimension d notice that on the
one hand we have a fixed size of this
Bell scenario but we also have a choice
of how big we take these Hilbert spaces
to be therefore in the end of how big
this tensor product Hilbert space is
here is an example another example we
have the bell table before this is a way
of realizing the Hardy model remember
with the Hardy model we could argue for
contextual T at the just at the possible
astac level and here is a suitable
choice of states and measurements that
will do that for us again we have a two
qubit system we the the
some measurement for Alice and for Bob
will just be measurement in the
computational basis
labeled by zero and one and then the
other measurements will will be these
slightly ugly looking things here and
the state is taken to be this two qubit
state this is just a choice but the
important point since or remember all we
needed to make the Hardy the hardy
pseudo ku argument go through was was to
have zeros in three places and I and the
positive probability in the other place
these choices do give us the zeroes in
the appropriate entries of the table and
they give a positive probability in the
top left entry these are there's a joint
outcome zero zero for these measurements
of which is actually very near the
maximum attainable value as I'm and
therefore the possible estate collapse
of this model if we only remember what's
probability zero or greater than zero is
indeed a Hardy model and we get that
stronger form of contextual 'ti as I
mentioned last time there's a general
result that says given any entangled
state with just this exceptional class
of maximally entangled bipartite states
but given any other entangled n-cubed
state we can find some measurements from
which we will get local choices of
measurements for allit for the end
parties which will witness harvey model
this form of nonlocality okay so how bad
is this class qmd well it's well
depending on what you think is bad I
think Dexter cozen has said you can't do
anything in program verification in less
than P space anyway this class is in P
space and in a fairly simple way so
we're fixing the dimension and the
condition for Ric quantum realization
after all we're saying there exists a
state and there exists local observables
such as if you compute out those inner
products and so on you end up with these
entries so you're fixing the
also you know what the entries are and
you could write all of that as in the
end as a big existential formula in that
since you could represent complex
numbers as pairs of real numbers you can
represent it all as some existential
sentence in the theory of real closed
fields and as is well known this
fragment has peace based complexity so
the membership of this class is in is in
peace base but that's for a fixed
dimension of hilbert space because of
course that allows you to write a
formula of a fixed size because you know
how big the how many entries the
matrices are going to have so we now
come to the well the first version of
the decision problem can we bound the
dimension D effectively so that the
class qm itself is decidable so because
obviously what we can do is to keep
bumping up the dimension and applying
this piece base algorithm and so at
least we would know that if you could
ever realize if in finite dimensions you
would get there in the end
but can we bound how big you have to
look at and intuitively you think you
could because after all this is a fixed
finite table I mean how big does there
should the hilbert space need to be but
we don't know the answer so a beautiful
piece of work recently in the quantum
information literature is answering a
complimentary question it's giving an
algorithmic way of determining when a
model is not quantum realizable so
directly answering in a general way fo
Kiana's question and this is due to
miguel neva squares stefano Boronia
Antonius in the NPA hierarchy so what
they give is a convergent hierarchy of
semi-definite programs characterizing
the set of quantum correlation so it's
an infinite hierarchy of conditions
expressed a semi definite program so as
we said the non contextual set is is is
a polytope defined by linear constraints
the no signaling set is a polytope
defined by linear constraints but when
we start writing out the formulas for
quantum realization we certainly get
going to get into quadratic constraints
and we need a richer class of of
programs semi definite programs and we
get this hierarchy which is sort of a
could be seen as some kind of non
commutative version of one of the
hierarchies have been studied a lot
recently in recent work in algorithms
relaxation hierarchies each successive
semi definite program runs in polynomial
time in its given program size but of
course that grows very rapidly in fact
and essentially at level n so why do we
need to keep sort of iterating this
hierarchy because at level n we're
looking at conditions on n-fold products
of the projectors which would witness
the quantum realisability of the model
by the way they do use the projective
measurements appealing to the the
dilation theorem and so on which we
mentioned earlier and so you get it's
like a word problem where even though
you start off from a finite amount of
data you keep getting sort of longer and
longer conditions that you need to
verify and what they prove is that the
sequence of tests is complete so we get
that we get a descending family of sets
that are filtered out by means of this
hierarchy of semi definite programs so
in the limit you you know that if a
model passes all the tests it is in this
set QM and if it fails any of the tests
it is not in QM this shows that the QM
is Co re the complement of an re set
but so you might think well okay I just
showed you that that if something was in
QM it's in about that's a now reset and
I we just said that it's kirari so put
them together and we might get a very
horrible from a complexity point of view
but nevertheless a decision procedure
for the set QA but there's a snag which
is rather interesting in order to have
enough room to put all these conditions
without kind of spoiling anything what
they actually can conclude is that if
something is in QM its it's not in any
of these finite dimensional hilbert
spaces but in infinite dimensional
hilbert space it's in the sequence Bay
well if you like in the sequence space
that separable Hilbert space so so
that's what they're actually proving now
there's an obvious so the question is is
there a difference between these finite
tables that you can realize in some
finite dimensional hilbert space and
those that you can realize in infinite
dimensional hilbert space on the first
sight it seems hard to believe that you
would really need an infinite
dimensional hilbert space to realize a
finite table
they have as a kind of result along the
way in their development they show that
the model admits a finite-dimensional
realization if and only if a certain
condition holds at some finite level of
the hierarchy but they can't show that
that condition will always hold if if
it's going to pass through all the tests
so and this is it seems to me around the
fascinating point this is a decision
problem but on the other hand saying
that the the tables the correlations
that you realize in a finite dimensional
space is the same as what you can
realize even an infinite dimensional
space has a clear physical significance
it's saying that to realize finite
tables of correlations I mean it to say
that they're different is to say that
something that seems pretty amazing that
to realize a finite table of
correlations we need infinitely many
degrees of freedom in the physical
system so I I think we have a purely
mathematical decision problem which I
think is a really nice problem for
magicians to to look at sort of and I
don't think it has been looked at from
that point of view as yet and on the
other hand a question with a clear
physical and operational content I
should also mention that there are
interesting connections on exact
equivalences but interesting connections
with some actually quite renowned open
questions in
in the world of operator algebras such
as the Khan embedding problem
essentially the knowing whether these
whoops whether these two things
correspond can be expressed in terms of
whether a certain sum C star algebra is
a residually finite and this relates to
these these known to be or believed to
be very hard open problems which has
certainly been open for quite some time
but it may be that logicians can prove a
result here this is a decision problem
which would shed light on these these
these open questions elsewhere in
mathematics yes yes yeah and the thing
is that as I say it's sort of for a
physical point of view you know it's
sort of a it would be extremely
interesting to know the answer and I
think it's it's again yet another
mystery I mean you know where does where
does in for the dimensions really come
in and what do we need it for but yes it
has exactly that analogy and I think
it's maybe a very good thing where
people coming from a logic point of view
can something to say okay well I guess
I've reached my end of my time so I was
going to say something very briefly
about constrained satisfaction but maybe
you'll say something about it anyway
I'll stop here so thanks but if there's
any quick question
want to realize community in the bail
scenario was to do ask for local
measurements right yes where is the NVRA
key actually
convergences says things are
unrealizable but not necessarily with
local measurements which anything
dimensions is different even though
acquired dimensions is to say that ours
for local measurements on bipartite
systems so you have three sets so you
know the things that are finite damage
realizing five dimensions yeah which are
contained in two things are realized in
infinite dimensions but where your
projection Asia over space and which I
contain the things our initiative
dimensions but we awake enough
projectors yes you just ask for
commutativity instead of commutativity
right right yes well there's another
right there's another issue there of the
Terrorism problem yes so there right so
there's another very interesting open
question so called torrelson problem
which is which relates to whether if you
have commuting families of operators
which would be like compatible
measurements if you can always represent
them on a tensor product and we know in
finite dimensions this is true and in
infinite dimensions the question is open
and that is strongly related to this
Kirchberg conjecture in fact and that
yes as really says we're kind of it
would assume positive answers as a
Saracen question to say that exactly
that notion of quantum realisability
would with local measurements would be
tested of course it does make a
difference if Alice and Bob have more
limited possibilities of each measuring
they're part of the system separately
than if we're well we well the question
it yeah so it still would have to be
commuting operators right yeah yeah okay
that's the point
yes so there's a number of delicate
questions in this area
to be commuting enough to be nervous
yeah
okay any other questions not weekend no
oh sorry
yes oh well I don't want to keep people
but I could say that that phone again
have done some really nice stuff on
there constraint satisfaction somewhat
inspired by some of these questions it's
led to some work on so called robust
constraint satisfaction so there was
some initial results from a couple of
years ago and they have I think a lot
more results now and the just to say
very briefly the idea of robustness is
that you're fixing the values of some of
the variables can you extend it to a
solution and if you remember our
discussion of the Hardy paradox we were
in a situation like that you fixed this
local section and the question was can
you extend it to a global one that would
be a sort of a solution for the whole
constraint satisfaction problem and it
turns out that this variant really leads
to some quite interesting sort of
developments that don't fall in the
standard path and you get a very nice
results about the tractability boundary
of this version of CSP
okay right